hi everyone
uh my name is shibaz yani and i'm a
postdoc at uben right now
and the paper i'm going to talk about
today is titled pipeline interventions
and this is joint work with aishwar
arunachala swarin
sampath cannon and aaron ross who are
also at hand
so today i want to tell you about
fairness and pipelines
and the reason i want to look at
pipelines today is because we know that
in real life
decisions buy and decisions about
individuals are
not made in isolation rather
those decisions are going to be made
throughout the pipeline throughout an
individual's life and decisions at
different stages of life
are going to have an effect and they're
going to compose with each other
so for example if i look at the
education and job market pipeline
well in this pipeline we can see how
each decision is going to fit into the
next
you can see that which preschool you're
going to go to is going to affect which
schools you can get into
which is going to affect which college
you can get into which is going to
affect your
employment opportunity etc etc
and the problem here is that in such
pipelines
well inequality of access to
opportunities disparities
can arise at each and at every stage of
such a pipeline
and then those disparities are going to
compose i know that the current
opportunities that i have today
are restricted by previous disparities
that i faced
in the past and if i want to look at the
flip side of this picture
i know that current disparities that i'm
facing
may have a long-term effect on what my
future opportunities are going to be
and even worse we know those disparities
can arise
even at very early stages let's say for
example at the preschool level
the question i want to ask is then where
are we going to intervene
in such a pipeline to eliminate or at
least
to reduce disparities and generally the
answer to that question
is not quite clear cuts
so if i look once again in the education
pipeline
well one preposition would be to
intervene at the college admission level
but in practice this might often be too
late
if we believe that disparities are going
to start at the preschool level
then maybe we should start having
interventions earlier in this pipeline
but at the same time if you intervene
very early in the pipeline it's going to
be hard to control the downstream and to
control the long-term effects of your
intervention
so really what i'm trying to get to
today is the fact that it might be
valuable to intervene
at several levels of such a pipeline
rather than just myopically and rather
than just at a single level
and once you start thinking about
intervening at several levels of a
pipeline
well you want to understand how
interventions at different stages
of your pipeline are going to compose
and then you want to see how this
understanding is going to inform how to
observe design
intervention at several stages several
levels of such a pipeline
in order to improve outcomes and to
reduce disparities across groups
so our main contribution first main
contribution in this paper
is to provide a stylized model to think
about those pipeline
interventions and i want to insist and
i'll get back to this later in this talk
that this is a very stylized model and
we just think of this as a first step as
a first model
and the goal of this model is to show
and to exhibit that it is actually
possible to think about such issues of
internet and pipelines
in a way that is formal and algorithmic
so our model is going to be the
following we are going to have a
graphical model
which is going to be comprised of
several layers
and then agents are going to start in
the first layer that we also call the
starting layer
and this layer is going to be comprised
of several starting nodes
and in this layer well different
starting nodes are going to correspond
to different starting groups or
different starting sub-populations
then agents are going to go through the
subsequent layers of the pipeline
sequentially and each subsequent layer
you can think of as corresponding to
stage of life
and each node on each layer you can
think of
as corresponding to the outcome of that
stage of life
so for example a layer could represent
your
college education and different notes on
that layer could represent different
education levels different types of
schools that you're going to
different majors for example
and finally our agents are going to end
up in the final
slash reward layer and so each node on
this reward layer is not i
is going to have a reward r of i
and this reward is a scalar measure of
the quality of the outcome that
corresponds to not i
so now i've told you that agents are
going to go through layers sequentially
but i haven't told you exactly how
individuals are going to go from one
layer to the next
and so here the way they're going to go
from one layer
to the next and progress through the
graph is via stochastic transition
matrices
so we're going to have stochastic
transitions between layers and those
stochastic transitions are going to
govern the probability of going from a
node on the current layer
to a node on the next layer
so for example there's going to be a
stochastic transition matrix
m of t between layers t and c plus one
and this transition matrix is going to
be such that m t of i j
is going to govern the probability that
an individual another i in layer at c
ends up in a j immersed c plus one
and i want to know that the stochastic
transition matrices can
actually model disparities and access to
opportunity
because you can give different groups
different probabilistic paths to
different reward notes through the graph
so some groups might be advantaged and
initially
might have high probability path to good
reward notes
versus some other groups may only have
high probability path towards
lower reward notes
and now remember that our goal in this
paper is to reduce disparities by
intervening on the pipeline
and so our intervention model here is
going to be the following
we'll take the point of view of a
centralized designer who can intervene
at any and at several stages of such a
pipeline
so you could think possibly of this
centralized designer as
the government or a government entity
that cares about education
and then an intervention is going to
consist into changing the stochastic
transition matrices between layers in
this graph
obviously you're not going to be able to
change
the transitions for free this is going
to come at a cost so changing
transitions between any two successive
layers is going to be costly to you
and as the centralized designer you will
have a constraint you will have a
maximum budget
that you can invest across all of the
layers and all of the transitions
so our cost function is going to look
like the following
so we're going to have a cost from
changing from an
initial transition matrix mt zero
between layers t and c plus one to a new
transition matrix m of t
and this cost is going to be given by c
of m t zero m t
and we're going to make a few
assumptions on this cost
the first assumption that we have to
make is that the cost is going to be
complex and empty so in the second
argument
and the reason we do so it's because
it's going to be necessary for us to do
any kind of optimization in this problem
and second we're going to impose an
entirely cheeseness condition
on cfmc0mt what the condition means
informally is that as you get further
away from
mtf zero you're going to increase the
cost of changing from mp0 to mt
so basically you cannot change or
improve transitions for free
and i just want to point out here that
the condition we use is not exactly
anti-elipsiousness we actually use a
weaker version of anti-aliciousness that
is more widely applicable
and then as i said before our
um centralized designer has a budget and
so we have a budget constraint which is
that the sum
of the costs that you spent on the
transition between any two layers c
and c plus one has to be less than b
and so our second contribution in this
paper is to provide algorithms to find
near optimal interventions
uh for our problem and so we use we have
algorithms that are going to find an
approximately optimal budget
split across all of the layers an
approximately optimal way to use the
budget to change transitions between
different layers
and our approach which i will give more
details about in the next couple slides
is going to rely on discretizing the
space of distributions on each layer so
the distribution
being here the probability of an agent
ending up in each node of that layer
and then we're going to combine this
with dynamic programming
and so the caveat here is that well our
dynamic program is going to be efficient
even if you have many many layers
but the problem is that because of the
discretization of the distribution
on each layer we're going to require
our algorithms to only deal with graphs
that have small
and constant layer width so the number
of nodes in each layer is going to have
to be small
we provide those algorithms for two
different objectives
the first one is to maximize the social
welfare or the expected reward of the
agents
given that you have a distribution over
which population which node agents are
going to start in
and really this objective if you think
about it for a second is the best
objective that can be achieved at the
level of the whole population
but it does not tell you anything about
how the welfare is going to be split
between different starting notes and
between different subpopulations
and so this actually might ignore
minority
and disadvantaged subrelations
to address this issue what we do is we
look at the second objective which is
the maximum objective
in which we're maximizing the welfare of
the worst off group
and you can think of this as being
basically parallel optimal you can think
of this as being the highest expected
reward
that can be achieved simultaneously for
all sub-populations
and you can think of it as if you were
to try to improve the welfare of any
group
one group is going to get worse welfare
than this maximin
welfare objective
so now let me tell you a bit more about
the techniques and about the dynamic
program that we use to find the
neuropsymbol social welfare
and let me start with the easiest case
in which we only have two layers and we
have a single transition matrix in the
needle
so now if you look at this picture on
the left side we're going to have a
starting distribution of our populations
so g of i is going to be the probability
that an agent is going to start
in uh node i on the starting layer
calculation i
and then we're going to have on the
right side rewards and r of i
is going to be the reward that you get
if you end up and now the i
in that layer in the in the reward layer
and we're going to have a transition
matrix m1 between the starting layer and
the reward layer
so here it's not hard to see that the
social welfare is just going to be
r times m1 times t so it's just going to
be a linear function of n1
plus so what you want to do now is you
want to maximize this
social warfare so this linear function
under the constraint
that the cost that you're using is less
than b
but remember that the cost is convex by
assumption so we get a convex constraint
and well we're done because we have an
easy to solve convex activation problem
so good we know how to deal with a
problem when we only have
one transition no what do we do when we
have many layers
well we're going to take a dynamic
programming approach
and this dynamic programming approach is
going to go backwards and it's going to
start from the last layer and then
build up up until we get back to the
first layer
so we want to start at the final layer
we want to start at the final transition
matrix
m of k between layers k and k plus 1.
and what we want to do here is we want
to solve the complex activation problem
that is similar to the one that
described to you before
we want to maximize the social welfare
given that we have a starting
distribution on layer k
that is called decay and that we have a
reward node
uh that we have rewords uh sorry on the
reward layer and those rewards are given
by
r so you want to solve the maximum of
r times mk times
let's decay under your
uh budget constraints
so what's the issue with this approach
here the issue with this approach
is that we don't know what decay is here
g of k
is going to depend on the early
transitions on the transitions from 1 to
k
but our dynamic programming is starting
from the end from the final layer
so we don't know what jfk is it's
unknown to us at this point in the
algorithm
so what are we going to do to solve this
problem well
we don't know dk we're just going to try
to guess it how do we try to guess decay
well this is where our discretization is
going to come in
we are going to try all of the possible
decays on mayor k
on an epsilon net of the probability
distributions of where agents
and between nodes want to w american
no the problem is that
since we have a w dimensional
probability distribution we need this
net that is going to have
size uh an epsilon net that's going to
have size
of roughly of one over epsilon to the
power of w
so we're only going to be able to deal
with constant and small values of w
but now once we've done this well for
every decay on the net all we have to do
is to solve the optimization program
that i was talking about in the previous
slides
and so we're going to do this
recursively until we get to the first
layer
and what's going to happen here is that
the nets that we're using this epsilon
net is going to make us lose
epsilon in welfare at each time step
so we will get a k epsilon approximation
to the social welfare if we have k
transitions
in terms of computational efficiency
remember that each step
requires looking at polynomially many
possibilities in one over epsilon
to the power of w because of the
discretization
so we're going to need w to be constant
but as long as w
is constant we'll be fine and you can
think of w being constant as this being
a chorus grouping of
outcomes in each stage
and then we're only going to need to do
these k times once again
so this is going to be computationally
efficient as long as w is constant for
it
but even for big values of k
and the final thing that i want to point
out here is that i've
talked about the dynamic program in the
context
of maximizing social welfare but this
can
easily be extended for maximum objective
and instead of keeping track of all of
possible deities at the start
to do that instead of keeping track of
all possible deities at the start of irt
we're going to keep track of slightly
more fine-grained information
and we'll keep track of a distribution t
of t and i which is going to depend on
each starting non-i so there's going to
be now in our dynamic program at every
time step
starting there's going to be a
distribution for every starting node i
and then we'll use pretty much the same
approach as before
now remember that i told you already a
couple times that
we can only deal with the case when
w has constant width and here i just
want to give you some quick intuition of
why this is actually
not something we can avoid and i want to
give you some quick intuition on our
hardness of approximation results so in
the paper we will show that it's
impossible
to approximate um
[Music]
the optimal minimax welfare to any
constant factor in the
general case and the way you can do that
is via a reduction to vertex cover
so start with a graph g
and for each edge you v in this graph
you can build the following pipeline
intervention problem that i have
on the slide so basically what you want
to do
here is you take the hgv and each edge
uv is going to correspond to
a single starting node and the starting
layer of our pipeline intervention
problem
and then in our pipeline intervention
problems we're going to have two reward
nodes
we're going to have the good one that
gives you a reward of one
and the bad one that gives you a reward
of zero
now in the pipeline intervention problem
that we construct
there is going to be one path pfu that
goes through the graph
for every node u in the original graph
so for example remember that there is
a vertex in the starting node in the
starting layer of our pipeline
intervention problem u of v
for every edge uv in the original
problem in the original graph and so
there's going to be here
two paths that are going to go from uv
to the final layer
there's going to be a path pu
and there's going to be a path p of v so
there is going to be a path pu
corresponding to vertex u and there is
going to be a path p
of v corresponding to vertex v and then
you're going to transition from uv to
each of those two paths with probability
one-half
so now also note that if i had another
edge
say uw in the original graph that has u
as a vertex
well it will share the same path p u as
the starting vertex uv
and just a quick note uh so forget about
the x's that we have
uh on this graph those x's are just
dummy notes that we introduced to make
sure
that we actually have a probability
distribution that sums to one
for each transition matrix but they're
not very important
and now here the idea is going to be
that the most efficient thing to do
if you want to optimize the maximum
welfare in this problem
is to use as few paths as possible that
are going to the reward node 1
but you also don't want to ignore any
starting
vertex you want to have a path that's
going to one for each edge
if you have a starting edge if you have
a starting vertex uv
that goes mostly to zero that must
detect the path that mostly goes to zero
then basically this starting population
the starting uv
is getting low welfare and so the mini
max welfare is going to be bad
but remember that each path just
corresponds to a node
in the original graph and basically
using as few paths as possible is going
to be equivalent to using as few
vertices as possible in the original
graph in the original
vertex cover problem
and so that's the general intuition of
the reduction between vertex cover and
our pipeline intervention problem
finally i want to point out in this talk
that we
have some price affirmative results and
in this paper we define the price of
fairness
as the optimal social welfare that you
can get
in our pipeline intervention problem
divided by
the social welfare of a maximum solution
and we're going to characterize the
price of well the price of fairness in a
very simple case
in which the costs are going to be
linear and so basically the cost for
changing a transition by one is going to
be exactly one
and in this case we're going to be able
to give tight bounce on the price of
fairness
and the expressions themselves are
not too important but what i really want
to point out here
is that if you look at the price of
fairness this price the furnace is first
not going to depend on
k the length of the craft it's only
going to depend on the width
w and the budget second
as the width is going to get bigger and
bigger it's obviously going to be harder
and harder to
uh give good welfare to everyone to
every starting population
and so if the price of fairness is going
to worsen
asw is getting bigger and finally as
b is also getting bigger it's going to
be easier and easier
to get the price of hardness close to
one and to improve the price of fairness
and if you have large enough budget if
you have a lot of budget
you can basically ensure that everyone
is going to have a path
that goes to the highest reward node
with probability one
and so the maximum solution and the
optimal solution are going to be the
same thing and the price of fairness is
so i want to conclude this talk on some
remarks about our model and some future
directions
so once again i want to insist here that
we're not solving all the questions
that rather we're still trying to only
provide the first tape and stylized
model to show that we can think about
those problems theoretically and
formally
but in practice there are many important
future directions
and some of those directions are that
first if you
intervene early in the pipeline it might
change transitions
not only in that layer in the first
layer but also
later in the pipeline and later stages
also in practice we know that
transitions between the two
beyond the transition from layer one to
layer two can be different for different
populations
so even if you have two starting
populations that end up in the same node
in mirror two they might still face
different transitions at points and so
it'd be nice to look at this in future
work
i also want to point out in practice
transitions may not be stochastic but
they may
involve strategic elements agents
don't decisions don't just happen to
them agents are
also going to make choices and they're
also going to make decisions
also our model is ac click and does not
take
back loops into account so it'd be very
nice in future work to be able to take
this
back loop into account our
reward model is simplified so basically
our reward model is such that
the reward is scalar and everyone has
the same reward on the same note so
everyone wants the same outcomes but in
practice in real life different agents
may want different outcomes
have different objectives and also be
very interesting to see what happens
if we have we don't have a centralized
designer we have different entities that
could intervene at different stages
and those are only some of the questions
there are many questions that we can ask
in our fairness and pipeline
interventions
um once again this is just a first step
to show that we can think about those
issues and we hope
that this paper is going to inspire a
lot of important and interesting future
work
and that's all i wanted to talk about
today so thank you very much for
listening